hi in this video I'll be talking about
glycogenolysis so if we break down the
term its glycogen and lysis so basically
it means breaking down of glycogen
so simply glycogenolysis is the process
by which big glucose polymer or you can
imagine them as collagen is broken down
into sin single glucose residues but
before understanding glycogenolysis we
should ask ourself where does it take
place when does it take place and how
does it take place so let's answer these
question in this video to understand the
concept behind glycogenolysis and in
this video i would also give a real-life
example where glycogenolysis take place
and it is essential for your body's
physiology so stay tuned till the end of
the video now the site for
glycogenolysis is muscle and liver so
that answers our question where does it
take place but why does it take place in
muscle and liver simply because all the
enzymes such as glycogen phosphorylase
tea branch in the enzyme and
phosphoglucomutase these enzymes which
are essential for glycogenolysis is
present in the liver and the muscle and
second of all the substrate that means
glycogen which is broken down into
glucose is actually stored in muscle and
liver as a reserve for glucose so that
is why this is the primary site for
glycogen Rises now then ask that when
does it take place one after situation
when glycogenolysis is important it is
starved State so in starch State what
happens is the body is deprived of any
kind of external nutrition intact so
what is has to like break down its own
glycogen reserve in order to produce
energy so simply the liver glycogen and
the muscle glycogen would be broken down
in order to produce glucose and that
could be used in the body to produce
energy and especially brain need glucose
as a fuel right so let
talk about glycogen a bit so glycogen is
like a globule so it has one particular
protein known as glycogen and that works
like a nucleation factor around which
the glycogen polymer which is basically
a chain of glucose exists and this
glycogen is a branched polymer now let's
simplify that structure to this way so
glycogen in is linking all the branched
polymers together and forming like a
globular structure so the glycogen has
two major kind of linkage one is alpha
1-4 glycosidic linkage that is the
straight chain and the branch chain has
alpha 1-6 glycosidic linkage why this is
important I'll talk in a bit so the key
enzyme for glycogenolysis is glycogen
phosphorylase so go ahead and
phosphorylase basically sits on the
alpha 1-4 glycosidic bond and by
enzymatic reaction it breaks the bond
and that is why it that is how it free
away the glucose receipt you and also
there is a phosphate group in the
glycogen phosphorylase which basically
phosphorylate the glucose and forms at
Lucas one phosphate residue that's the
product now in proceed to the branched
end till fourth amino acid before the
fourth for glycogen residue before the
branch point so let's talk about the
glycogen phosphorylase in a bit
so whoever gene phosphorylase has a
paradoxical group or PLP which is
basically derived from vitamin b6 at the
catalytic site and it has two catalytic
sites and each of these catalytic site
has PRP and PLP has a very important
role in the enzymatic reaction mechanism
and it forms a safe base with the basic
amino acid lysine 680 and in a moment we
would understand why it is important so
what happens in phosphorylase breaks
alpha 1-4 glycosidic linkage right so in
in a couple of minute we would
understand that what is the mechanism
behind that so here is glycogen
phosphorylase and here is active site
quite literally phosphorylase so what
you can see is that the phosphate the
the oxygen from the alpha 1-4 glycosidic
linkage is basically getting protonated
and further it gets a nucleophilic
attack from the phosphate group itself
which would make the glucose into a
glucose 1-phosphate
and leave the glycogen with one less
glucose residue and this is how
progressively the glycogen polymer would
be degraded into glucose 1-phosphate
residues now whenever the glycogen
phosphorylase gets to the end of a
branch point at least four residues away
from the branch point it halts now then
glycogen phosphorylase gets replaced by
a debranching enzyme now debranching
enzyme are special because debranching
enzyme can prick the alpha 1-6
glycosidic linkage which glycogen
phosphorylase can't break so debranching
enzyme would break the offer 1-6
glycosidic linkage and make it a linear
chain of glucose right now and once it
is a linear chain of glucose our
glycogen phosphorylase can again attach
and start breaking down the chain again
so this is how glycogen phosphorylase is
one of the rate-limiting enzyme in
glycogenolysis
and we know how now once the glucose
residues are broken down and in format
of glucose 1-phosphate
now let's see what happens to these
glucose 1-phosphate so cucas one
phosphate with the action of
phosphoglucomutase is getting converted
into glucose 6-phosphate now
phosphoglucomutase has a phosphate group
now this phosphoglucomutase is getting a
nucleophilic attack from the oxygen
which is attached to this carbon number
six in the glucose 1-phosphate
and as a result what is happening it is
forming a transient intermediate known
as glucose 1 6 bisphosphate
and forming a serine residue insider'
for forceful saline residue in the
phosphoglucomutase enzyme catalytic site
now a further reaction which is another
nucleophilic attack to the blue carbon
residue you want converts this whole
thing to glucose 6-phosphate so that is
how by the enzymatic action of
phosphoglucomutase glucose 1-phosphate
is getting converted into glucose
6-phosphate now glucose 6-phosphate
is a very important intermediate because
glucose 6-phosphate
can either enter the glycolysis and in
the glycolytic pathway it can form the
pyruvate or it can also enter the Pintas
phosphate pathway where it can produce
nadph and ultimately give rise to ribose
5-phosphate which could be used for
nucleotide biosynthesis and all so how
the glucose 6-phosphate would be
utilized it's a matter of body's
metabolic demand for example if the body
requires energy it would quickly use the
glucose 6-phosphate
into pyruvate and produce energy that
would provide body instant energy but if
the body needs
anabolic responses such as fatty acid
biosynthesis cholesterol biosynthesis
etc etc then body would produce more
energy pH or body needs a lot of
transcriptional activity or a lot of
gene expression to be happened then it
would choose the pentose phosphate
pathway to channel the glucose
6-phosphate into that pathway now it
entirely depends where the glucose
6-phosphate would be channeled in
pentose phosphate pathway or in
glycolysis and it all depends upon the
external demand so let me give you an
example so let's say you are standing on
a dog's tail and that that dog is like
mad over you and trying to chase you and
you are like health care so definitely
your muscles need to move and
immediately your muscles need a hell
of glucose but after a while your muscle
glucose is depleted but still you need
to run to avoid the dog bite and that is
why you need to break down glycogen in
your muscle to produce glucose and that
could power up your muscle right so one
hormone which is epinephrine or
adrenaline it's regulating the glycogen
breakdown upon this kind of
flight-or-fight situation so adrenaline
binds to etre najuk receptors on the
muscle cells and in the G couple
signaling mechanism takes place which
ultimately leads to cyclic AMP
regeneration and cyclic a.m. P dependent
kinase or PKA is activated the PK a
catalytic subunit actually activates
phosphorylase kinase and phosphorylase
kinase is an important regulatory enzyme
so whom does it regulate phosphorylate
kinase actually phosphorylate the
glycogen phosphorylase now we have
already learned that glycogen
phosphorylase is so important to break
down the alpha 1-4 glycosidic linkage
and thereby breaking down glycogen into
glucose so thereby the hormonal control
to a immediate flight-or-fight response
would increase the phosphorylase
activity which can eventually break
glycogen into glucose and give the
muscle instant source for glucose to
channel it into glycolysis pathway and
Krebs cycle to get the energy and that
could provide your pump your muscle up
for running and and save your life right
that is how the hormonal control is
important over metabolic pathways in
order to save our body's physiology so I
hope you enjoyed this video if you liked
this video give it a thumbs up don't
forget to Like share and subscribe think